welcome to introduction to programming
my name is Steven and my name is Sean
over the next 90 minutes we'll be taking
you through this series consisting of 21
different segments that hope to cover
the basics of computer programming which
can apply to any and all programming
languages you might want to learn we'll
be starting with the simplest question
of what is programming and from there we
will be working our way up as we talk
about common features of computer
science such as loops and arrays will
discuss how to read and write code debug
code that you've written some strategies
to help you plan out your code and much
much more
the complete list of topics that are
going to be covered in this lecture
style video are shown on the screen now
additionally there will be timestamps in
the description so feel free to skip
around if you are already proficient in
some areas of computer science or just
want to know about a specific topic we
will be covering hopefully by the end of
the series you'll have a basic
understanding of what computer sciences
along with an armoury of useful skills
that will help you unravel
whichever programming language you
decide to learn first we'll only be
covering the major key points that apply
to all programming languages so we'll be
shying away from topics such as
object-oriented coding and command-line
navigation as those are things which are
language specific additionally there
will be no software required for you to
download in order to follow along with
this tutorial as we won't be writing any
code in an IDE
to keep things simple and concentrated
this video is meant for those who are
interested in computer science and
programming but have no idea where to
start and have little to no background
information on coding and so if that
sounds like you then strap in as Sean
and I work our way through the wacky
world of computer science starting with
the biggest question probably on your
mind which is what even is programming
well the dictionary defines it as the
process of preparing an instructional
program for a device but that's a really
confusing definition so in layman's
terms what exactly does that mean
essentially it is attempting to get a
computer to complete a specific task
without making mistakes imagine this for
example you want your less than
intelligent friend to build a Lego set
except he has lost the instructions and
can only build it based on your commands
remember though your friend is far from
competent and so if they are not given
very specific instructions on how to
build the set there are many mistakes
that they could make if he thinks like a
computer then if there is even one piece
that you have not told them specifically
where to place and how to place it the
entire Lego set will be ruined and you
will be left to suffer a complete mental
breakdown causing the whole goal of of
the project to be corrupted giving
instructions to your friend is very
similar to how programmers code instead
of a less than intelligent friend you
have a less than intelligent computer
and instead of instructions on how to
put a Lego set we are feeding it
information on how to complete a program
like a game or a web application an
important thing to note is that
computers are actually very dumb we
built them up to be this super
sophisticated piece of technology when
in actuality a computer's main
functionality comes from how we
manipulate it to serve our needs
now programming isn't as simple as
giving your friend instructions since in
a programmers case the computer doesn't
speak the same language as you the
computer only understands machine code
which is a numerical language known as
binary that is designed so that the
computer can quickly read it and carry
out its instructions every instruction
fed to the computer is converted into a
string of ones and zeros and then
interpreted by the computer to carry out
a task going back to the Lego example
this process would be like if he was not
only less than intelligent but to make
matters worse he could not understand
English and only speaks in Mandarin
Chinese in order to speak with him
you have to convert the instructions
that you understand in English into the
language that your friend understands
this process is essentially what you
must do for your computer in order to
make it understand the instructions that
you give it the big difference between
the two examples however is that it is
very difficult for people to understand
machine code in binary directly
translating what you want the computer
to do into machine code is extremely
difficult
in fact almost impossible and will take
a very long time to do it if you could
each program is composed of millions
upon millions of those ones and zeros so
how exactly are we supposed to translate
our instructions into machine code
this is where programming languages come
into play programming languages are
fundamentally a middleman for
translating a program into machine code
these languages are much easier for
humans to learn than machine code and
thus are very useful for programmers
going back to our lego example a
programming language would sort of be
like an interpreter that's able to take
the instructions you give them in
English and translate them into
instructions your non-english speaking
friend can understand this makes
programming languages extremely useful
and the backbone of any good program
think of programming languages as not
English and not machine code but
somewhere in the middle there are many
different programming languages out
there that each have their own unique
uses languages such as Python and Java
act as general-purpose languages that
can perform a variety of computational
tasks while robot C or HTML or CSS our
language is designed for more specific
purposes such as moving a robot or
constructing a website languages can
also vary in how powerful they are
for instance javascript is a scripting
language that is designed for smaller
tasks or Java or Python and carry out
much more computationally taxing
processes we can measure a programming
languages power or level by how similar
it is to machine code this series of
zeros and ones we talked about earlier
low-level programming languages such as
assembly or C are closer to binary in a
high-level programming language such as
Java or Python the basic idea is that
the lower the level of your programming
language the more your code will
resemble what the machine can interpret
as instructions aside from the different
purposes that each language fulfills
choosing a language typically comes down
to a matter of preference as are usually
many languages that can accomplish
similar tasks try different languages
and decide which ones rules interface
and level of simplification you like
best
so now that we know what programming is
how do we actually write code it's not
like we can simply type words into a
text document and automatically assume
that the computer can translate it into
machine code read it and carry out a
task like opening up a browser and
additionally we can't just write down
rubbish in certain programming languages
mentioned in the previous segment and
expect the computer to understand so how
are we supposed to write code then well
the answer is with an IDE an IDE which
stands for integrated development
environment allows the facilitation of
code by a computer I des provide a
graphic interface on your computer in
which the programmer can easily write
run and debug code without having to
worry about problems with complication
or interpretation of the program think
of an IDE as any other program on your
computer such as a game a browser or
even the File Explorer except we'll be
using it to write code IDs are able to
turn your code into machine code and run
it through the computer to produce
results in addition to providing a place
for programmers to develop their code
IDs provide some extremely useful tools
for programmers to ease the job of
writing code such as built-in error
checking because as we'll talk about
later code doesn't always run correctly
auto-filling for frequently used words
or phrases and a project hierarchy which
will help you organize and manipulate
the files within your project back in
the olden days before IDs
code used to be written on punch cards
and then fed into computers which would
take hours and cause a lot of pain ids
nowadays act as sort of a fast-track to
writing code and make things a whole lot
easier for programmers an example of a
specific IDE can be seen on your screen
now in the center you can see the
program that is currently being written
and right below it is the console which
can print out useful information for the
programmer this specific IDE is used to
write java code i des are extremely
powerful and will be used in almost a
hundred percent of your programming
projects so through these ideas we are
finally able to write and compiled code
smoothly without worrying about the
computer not being able to understand it
the next problem we run into then
becomes how do we write this code in the
IDE because it's not like we can just
type random words from a certain
programming language and expect the
computer to understand this is where a
programming languages syntax comes into
play
now just as if you were learned in a
real language learning a computer
language can be very similar some have
different style
that may seem odd some may make you use
weird or abstract concepts which may be
confusing and like all languages
programming languages have a set of
rules that you must follow when writing
code in that language and at the
forefront of those rules is grammar
programming grammar is referred to as
syntax and is very similar to real-world
grammar each programming language has
its own syntax or rules that you have to
follow to a T if you want your program
to run correctly just as if you were
speaking in real life
these can be things such as how you type
out certain functions what you put at
the end of a line of code and how you
set up certain functions each language
is unique in its syntax and while some
may share similar rules all will have
some quirk which makes it stand out from
the rest
syntax is something that catches a lot
of people off-guard
since many expect every programming
language to follow the same set of rules
but as we spoke about in the last
segment because each language is
specialized for a specific task each
needs its own set of rules to function
breaking or disregarding these rules
will result in an error just how
breaking or disregarding rules in real
life will result in an unintended
message as an example if you wanted to
do something simple such as initialize a
variable which is something that we
haven't covered yet but the example is
still relevant in Java you'll notice how
we have to specify what type of variable
we are defining in this case an integer
and also at a semicolon after the
statement in Python we don't even need
to define that we are trying to create a
variable and just have to type what we
want to create and in JavaScript we just
specify that we are making a variable
but we don't include what type of
variable we want to make like in Java
even in this simple example you can see
how much of syntax matters when learning
a new language since while the goal of
our program remain the same which was to
define of the integer with the value 3
all the programming language is shown
took different approaches all these
languages require that you follow this
syntax because remember computers are
extremely dumb if you forget one
semicolon or misplace a character the
entire program will not run and send you
back a syntax error which is something
we'll talk about later think of this as
if you forget a comma in a sentence and
the entire context of what you're trying
to say gets misinterpreted for example
in the sentence let's eat grandma
if you were to forget that comma well it
may seem like a small mistake it changes
the entire context of the sentence
making it sound like you're going to eat
your grandma the same rules follow for
programming if you forget a semicolon
the entire context of your program could
be corrupted and misinterpreted by the
IDE now another thing which makes IDE so
useful is that they will let you know if
and when there are syntax errors in your
code syntax errors of course being in
parts of your code which do not follow
the same rules we talked about
previously the IDE will tell you where
in your code the errors and also won't
let you run your program until the error
has been fixed because of how important
syntax is to writing code and learning a
new language it's recommended that you
learn the rules and syntax of a language
before beginning to write complex
programs in that language most of the
rules are tedious to learn but easy to
master and as soon as you can do that
you'll be able to easily identify syntax
errors and take care of them easily and
be writing code in no time that covers
the basic gist of syntax and programming
rules so now that we know how to write
code and the where to write code we next
need to cover what happens after we have
typed out a program and run our code
because writing a piece of code for a
game or for a database is cool and all
but after the computer interprets the
program how will we know what's
happening and whether or not is working
well programmers do this by looking at
the console the console is a text
interface within your computer the us
programmers can use for a variety of
different purposes if you remember a
short while ago we covered a picture of
a basic IDE and one of the main parts of
the picture was the console the main use
of the console is to output text from
the program this is usually done by
using a print statement a print
statement is a command that does exactly
what it sounds like it prints text to
the console the print statement is the
first piece of actual code we've talked
about in this series and it's about as
simple as a kiss the purge statement
despite its simplicity is one of the
most important functions in programming
and exists in some form in just about
every programming language the most
basic thing you can ask the print
statement to do is to just simply make
it say something this is done by
instructing the console to print and
then include wherever you want to be
printed inside the parenthesis for
example in Python the segments of code
print hello world will cause a message
reading hello world to appear on to the
console pretty neat the print statement
is also vital for viewing
interpreting the computer's output firm
program for instance if you can tell a
computer to run a simple calculation for
example to determine what 4 plus 3 is it
will run the program internally and
compute and answer however what is the
purpose of having the computer run this
program if you were not be able to tell
what the result is instead of simply
tell them the computer to perform this
calculation instruct the computer to
print the output of the program to the
console and prime the program's
completion 7 will appear on the console
as you can see the console loves to
easily print information out to the
developer for a variety of uses it is
important to note that the print
statement varies depending on the
programming language being used for
example in Java there are multiple
versions of the print statement
depending upon whether you would like a
line break after the printed text or not
as well as specialized print statements
which make your code run more
efficiently also the general syntax of
using a print statement and certain
nuances of its function contains between
languages however you can generally rely
on it to carry out the same overall
function as it is foundational statement
for programming in general all of its
functionality makes the print statement
along with the console a very useful
developer tool however it is important
to remember that that is all it is in
the developer tool the console is not
really meant to be viewed by the end
user of your program it tends to be
hidden away behind the scenes and other
methods of displaying information such
as displaying text graphics or images
are used to convey information to the
user instead think of it like this when
you are using your phone you see the
console and none of the programs you use
so while you can use the console to give
yourself information about how your
program is performing don't try to
implement it in the final product
because it fundamentally just isn't
meant for that overall remember to use
the console to its fullest extent
when writing and fixing problems in your
programs as it is a great tool to use to
tell how your program is performing
behind the scenes
so now that we know a bunch of
information about programming languages
and how and where to write them along
with the print statement under our belts
let's go over some intuitive things that
the computer can do all by itself
without you having to tell it how to
more specifically we'll be covering some
basic number mathematics as well as
string math starting off with basic
mathematics the computer already knows
how to do simple arithmetic this
includes addition subtraction
multiplication and division all of which
are represented by the symbols shown on
the screen now in any IDE that you may
install you'll be able to print out the
answer to simple math problems using the
print statement which may seem
counterintuitive because why would you
use the computer to do math when you
have a perfectly good calculator on your
phone you have to remember that
computers are dumb and anything we want
a computer to do we have to build up
from scratch basic arithmetic while
simple helps out in almost any program
you may write for example if we wanted
to build a basic calculator app we'd
need to utilize this functionality in
order to correctly display the answer to
an arithmetic problem when our user
tries to add subtract multiply or divide
two numbers now in addition to the four
basic math equations most programming
languages include an additional operator
known as modulus if this is your first
time hearing this word don't worry
since it's not usually taught in math
classes modulus allows us to get the
remainder of a divisional operation for
example when we take 10 modulus 3 we are
essentially telling the computer to take
ten divided by three ignore the actual
answer and just give us the remainder of
the operation in this case 1 since when
we divide 10 by 1 the answer is 3
remainder 1 the 1 in this case is what
gets printed out to the console if there
is no remainder say in the case that we
take 50 modulus 2 since the remainder is
0 the function would return 0 if we were
to print it out to the console this can
be extremely useful in many cases the
most obvious being if we want to
determine whether or not a certain
integer is even or odd if we take a
certain number modulus 2 and it returns
zero then we know that is even because
any number divided by 2 will always
result in a full answer without a
remainder
but if the system returns one then we
know that the integer is odd you will
find yourself using the basic math
operators a lot more than you think
so it's good to keep them in mind when
writing your program now not only can
our computer work with numbers but it
can also work with strings strings by
the way are just another way to save
text for example hello world is a string
the letter A is a string and anything
enclosed by quotation marks is denoted
as a string in programming languages
we'll cover more about strings in a bit
when we talk about variables but for now
let's continue we already talked about
printing strings to the console well
let's say we're making a game and we
wanted to print out the statement game
over for was your final score now while
we could just make a string that says
that exact phrase and print it out to
the console in some cases it would be
more useful to print out the actual
integer value especially in the case of
a game where the score can change each
time you play because score definitely
isn't always going to be 4 well we're
also able to print out multiple strings
of texts and even integers by adding
them together in the print statement
this is known as concatenation
continuing with our scorer example if we
wanted to print out the statement game
over for was your final score using 4 is
an integer rather than a string we could
do this by breaking down the statement
into two strings and an integer like so
print game over plus four plus was your
final score
we of course begin with the print
statement which again will be different
across all languages but in this case
we're using Python inside the print
statement we start off by printing the
string game over now here comes the
important part from there we use a plus
sign and add four to the print statement
just like if you were adding two numbers
then we can repeat this process with
another plus sign for the final string
was your final score and we're able to
print out the entirety of our statement
easily doing this we can easily print
out multiple different strings and
integers together in one print statement
we could also combine the two lessons
we've learned thus far and do something
such as game over plus four plus four
plus was your final score in the case
let's say where you have a game
which gives you a base score and then
four points for a certain task that you
completed this demonstration also
displays another important part of
programming which is that oftentimes to
get your program to be the most
efficient you have to combine aspects of
code now it's important to note that the
computer will take whatever you put in
the parenthesis and print it out
character for character so oftentimes
programmers will forget to add a space
onto the end of their strings this can
result in a small mistake in which the
string from the previous example would
be printed out as if to say game over
for was your final score which isn't
that appealing when displayed on the
screen to the user so it's a good
practice to always put a space after and
before your strings to make sure this
doesn't happen and your string doesn't
end up like that another important thing
to note is the difference between four
in quotation marks and four without
quotation marks now four in quotation
marks is treated as a string rather than
a four without quotation marks which is
treated as a number this may not seem
like a big deal but again computers are
dumb and if you try to do math with a
number in quotation marks it will return
an error because the computer doesn't
understand that you're trying to perform
the operation on a number and it thinks
you're trying to add an integer to a
string which is a big no-no in
programming when you're adding numbers
so when you're programming make sure to
make a mental note of whether or not you
want to make something an integer or a
string because that type of stuff it
makes a big difference all right that
concludes our segment on the base power
of computers now next up we're going to
be covering one of the most important
components of computer science so make
sure you pay attention because next up
we're going to be discussing variables
what they are and how we use them first
of all what exactly is a variable a
variable is simply something that can
store information and can be referenced
and manipulated think of variable is
like a cardboard box cardboard boxes
service means to store items in them
which can be changed that replaced and
modified variables are like cardboard
boxes that store information for the
programmer to reference or manipulate
each variable simply has a type a name
and a piece of information stored inside
of it the type of piece of information
will be covered next and then name is
simply a name for the variable think of
it as writing out a label on the
cardboard box in sharpie
now there are many different types of
variables that a programmer can use but
right now we will just be covering what
I call it primitive variables which
include integers boolean x' floats and
doubles strings and characters we'll
start off by talking about an integer an
integer or int for short is as simple as
it sounds
a variable that can store an integer
value this includes all whole numbers
from negative 2 billion 147 million 480
3648 it's a 2 billion 147 million 480
3648 notice how I said whole numbers
entered values can not and will not hold
any decimal values so keep that in mind
when using variables secondly is a
boolean a boolean is very primitive
variable which can store a value of
either true or false boolean variables
can only hold these two values and are
extremely useful for conditional
statements which we will cover soon the
next two types of variables are floats
and doubles both of these variable types
are floating-point data types which
essentially means that these variables
can store numbers with decimal places
whereas integers values cannot hold
decimal values floats and doubles can
the main difference between the two is
that a float variable can store numbers
of our precision up to 32 bit while
doubles can store numbers with a
precision up to 64 bit essentially a
double can store more decimal places
than a float so it all comes down to how
precise you want the variable to be up
next we have string variables which are
like the strings we've talked about
beforehand except store somewhere in a
value string variables can store strings
of letters which are just words and
sentences strings are useful for
displaying text and storing input
information strings can also be
concatenated together to form
combinations of string variables and
pre-written strings this can be very
useful for outputting information in a
readable format for the user and for
example imagine we have a string called
name the code asks for input and stores
that string of text in name to output
this information to the user rather than
simply displaying their name you can add
the phrase your name is and make it into
a sentence by concatenating your name is
plus name plus a period this makes it
easier to read your code while also
adding variability to your code which
always makes things more interesting for
the end user
finally we have char variables charge
stands for character and just as the
name suggests they can each hold one
character this is useful when a
programmer wants to read one button
press or one character in a string
without using a string variable a
specific example is winning a game that
is controlled by the keyboard the
program needs to recognize the character
that is pressed and translate that into
carrying out some function now strings
can also hold one character but chars
can't hold more than one character so
keep that in mind when defining
variables now why are variables so
useful well being able to store
information in a format that can be
easily referenced later is essential for
any good program oftentimes in code
you're going to want to keep track of
things such as a user's name or score
and so by creating a variable called
name or score you can store this
information in the variable and then
reference it add to it or modify it also
many times the program will want to take
input from the user which cannot be
pre-programmed into the code and thus a
variable is required to store the
information a program may also rely on
factors that will change as the program
progresses in which case a variable is
once again required also taking these
variables and manipulating them it's
quite necessary for carrying out many of
the tests you want a program to carry
out for instance multiplying in
variables or concatenating string
variables over all variables are the
backbone of any good program and you'll
find yourself using them often if you
want to clean an efficient code so it's
best that you learn what types of
variables you need to use and win so now
that we know all about the different
variable types and we've talked about
them a little bit we're gonna delve
further into what happens when we
actually define create a variable how we
reference them and how we can manipulate
them for our programs to start let's go
over what happens when we actually
define a variable now when we write a
line of code which initializes a
variable and that code is executed the
computer essentially creates a little
space in memory that stores your
variable name and its contents so that
it can be referenced later going back to
our cardboard box example from the
previous segment think of this as if you
had your own storage facility and you
make a new cardboard box labeled name
and inside of it you put a piece of
paper with the word nullpointerexception
on it now anytime you want to know the
contents of your name box you could
simply look inside and see that it has
the contents nullpointerexception
this is what the computer does
except this storage facility is the
memory in your computer the box is a
variable and the contents of the box are
whatever the variable is set to be equal
to anytime you want to know the contents
of the name variable you can simply call
it and the computer will pull the
information that is stored in that
variable and use it how the users see
fits another thing to note really
quickly is that you can actually make a
variable without putting information
inside of it this would simply be like
if you built up a new cardboard box gave
it a label with a sharpie but just
didn't put information inside of it
you're simply saving that space in your
storage facility for later this could be
maybe because you want to store
information in it later down the road or
if you're going to use it to store
information given to you by the user in
which case you can't give it information
since you don't know what the user will
input just a note that if you try to
reference or point to a variable which
does not have any information in it
you'll get what's known as a
nullpointerexception
which despite being an amazing name for
a youtube channel is something you
generally want to avoid when programming
now programming languages allow us to do
some pretty cool things with these boxes
that we've created for example let's say
we created a second variable called
channel name and instead of setting it
equal to null pointer exception we
instead set it equal to our already
created named variable this doesn't
create a space in memory for this new
variable however it simply points the
same location of memory we have already
created for the name variable going back
to our storage facility example this
would be like instead of creating a
whole new box labeled channel name and
storing a sheet of paper with the word
nullpointerexception on it we instead
simply added another label below the
name box entitled channel name now we
have two variables which point to the
same contents that being the string
nullpointerexception
we usually do this to save space in our
code for things that we know are going
to have the same value variables can
also be updated throughout your code for
example let's say you had an age
variable and inside of it was the
integer 17 then you celebrated a
birthday and wanted to update your age
all you would have to do is reference
the variable
and set it equal to whatever new integer
you want the variable to hold in this
case 18 this would be the same as having
a box labeled age but the sheet of paper
eating 17 inside of it and then taking
that piece of paper out erasing 17
replacing it with 18 and then placing it
back in the box doing this we are able
to easily update the contents of our
variables throughout the code as things
dynamically shift as another example if
you are making an RPG your character
would likely have stats such as attack
defense mana etc as a game progressed
you could continuously update the
variables so that the player could get
more powerful the further along that
they went through the game and you
wouldn't have to create new variables
you would simply need to just keep
grabbing that box from your sword
facility erasing and replacing the
numbers on the piece of paper and then
continue along with your code just keep
in mind that these variables are nothing
more than places in memory and which a
certain value is stored so we can easily
update the numbers and their place will
remain constant after the code has run
its course the place in memory is
deleted until you run the code again and
the program dedicates space for the
variable again each time you run the
code you're making new boxes in your
storage facility and at the end of the
code you destroy them all to make room
for the new boxes next time another cool
thing you can do with integer float and
double variables is add them subtract
them divide them multiply them and even
modulus them for example if you are
making a calculator app and you store
the first number the user entered as
number one and the second as number two
you could then multiply num1 and num2
together and now they're print them or
soar them in a new variable entitled the
result then each time you run the
program the user could input new numbers
into the num1 and num2 variables and
they would simply be set to those new
integers that the user inputted and
returned the result that corresponds to
those specific numbers this allows you
to keep easy track of which numbers are
which and what's going on in your
program which is extremely useful also
while you cannot subtract multiply
divide or take the modulus of strings
you are able to add them like we said
previously let's say you had a string
str1 with the
hello and a string str2 with the
contents there you could add str1 and
str2 to create a string that the head
the contents hello there either storing
it in a third variable or printing it
out to the console the last topic we'll
be covering on the topic of variables is
the naming conventions of variables
which albeit may seem odd but it's
extremely important when trying to read
your code so we'll be covering it now
now variables have to be one continuous
string and so if you wanted to make a
variable that stored the players score
you'd have to find some way to combine
the words player and score since you
can't have the phrase player score be
the name of a variable all programmers
have their own personal preference when
it comes to naming variables but the one
we'll be using in this lecture is called
camelcase
which is the process of not capitalizing
the first word but capitalizing every
word that follows it going back to the
player scorer example using the
camelcase method the variable would be
called player score this allows us to
easily see and identify each word and
becomes really useful for long variable
names like the player's score before the
final boss
whereas if we just type it out without
camelcase it would be really confusing
and hard to read this will help you out
a ton when we start finding bugs in our
code and need to quickly scan through
our program to figure out what is wrong
and adds to the overall readability of
the program other programmers might use
different naming conventions like using
underscores to separate the words in a
phrase but for now in this series we'll
be sticking with camelcase
next we'll be moving on to conditional
statements which at their core are
statements that change the path of our
code depending on certain conditions for
the sake of keeping things simple for
this section where headlines will
connote that our code will not be
following the specific path in green
lines we mean our code is following the
path
the main type of conditional statement
that programmers use is the if statement
and this will show up countless amount
of times in any program you write it is
as simple as it sounds if some condition
is true and usually that condition will
be enclosed by braces then carry out the
instructions located within the if
statements brackets else do another
thing now
brackets are used in most programming
languages to indicate a segment of code
which will run it works like this if the
condition in parentheses is true then
all of the code contained within the
brackets will run and if the condition
within the parentheses is not true then
it will skip over all the statements
within the brackets a quick note is that
while this is the case with most
programming languages some like Python
use columns and whitespace to determine
where a piece of code starts and ends
but for the sake of this series we'll be
using curly braces now the condition
within the parentheses can take on
thousands of different forms such as if
the value of the string variable name is
equal to Steven or if the player's score
stored in an int variable is greater
than 5 the list goes on and on each of
these statements is evaluated as a
boolean which you will remember from
when we talked about variables is either
true or false if the boolean is true we
run the code inside the curly braces if
it's not we pretend everything inside
the curly braces never exists it and
move on with our code the if statement
comes with two more additional
statements that can go with it else if
and else else if is a conditional
statement used directly after an if
statement and carries out mainly the
same function as an if statement however
the else if statement will only be
evaluated if the proceeding if or the
preceding else if the statement is
bypassed due to its condition being
false so we would run through it like so
if something is true we would run the
code inside of that statements curly
braces else if that something is not
true but another statement inside of the
parentheses is true we would then run
that code segment and if neither of them
are true we would skip both segments of
code and move on in our program this can
be a hard concept to wrap your head
around so let's
do an example if we had a program that
evaluated the if statement if age is
equal to 10 we could then have a
statement under that which stated else
if age is equal to 12
now if the age variable was 10 which we
can see from the example that it is then
the code immediately following that
conditional statement in the brackets
would run the else's statement we made
will not even be tested since we know
that it is going to be false and thus
the print statement inside of that
conditional statement Break its will be
ignored and the code will move on to the
rest of the program now for example
let's say we change the age variable to
be 12 instead of 10 now instead of the
first conditional statement being true
it actually evaluates as false since age
is no longer equal to 10 so what we do
now is first skip over the print
statement which prints out that ages 10
since it's not and then we evaluate the
else if statement we check if age is
equal to 12 which again it is and so now
we run that all the code inside of that
conditional statement before finally
moving on to the rest of our program so
as a review we check the initial if
statement if it's good then we run all
of the code within that if statements
curly brackets and move on with our
program if the initial if statement is
not true we then move on to any else if
statements and evaluate if those
conditional statements are true where
you have as many else if statements as
we want although this could lead to
clutter amongst your code so we'll talk
about some alternatives later to help
this out now that takes care of the
if-else statement so now we'll move on
to the else statement the out statement
once again it comes after an if or an
out if statement and we'll carry out its
instructions no matter what as long as
the preceding statement slash statements
are evaluated as false if we went back
to our previous program we could add an
else statement which would only have the
code in his brackets run at the age
verba wasn't ten or twelve this will
catch all cases of the program that
didn't fit into our parameters it's a
good practice to always have an else
statement at the end of your conditional
statements to catch any weird cases that
may come up in your program
now remember back to the fact that we
could have thousands of else's
statements after a while that can get
pretty cluttered and so another very
useful conditional statement which helps
circumnavigate this problem is a switch
statement a switch statement is
functionally similar to many if and else
if statements together you write a
switch statement in the form of switch
variable and then below that you write
out how many cases the variable could be
for instance if we were to switch var
and then under way to write out five
cases that the variable var could be and
the instructions listed under each case
will be carried out if the very variable
would be equal to that case now switch
statements are different since instead
of using brackets they use a column to
signify the start of a set of
instructions and a break statement to
end them this is very useful because you
are able to essentially use many if and
else if statements without having to
write nearly as much in switch
statements you just always have to
remember to include a default case at
the bottom of the expression to denote
any and all cases that don't meet the
above requirements this simply catches
all B inputs that don't fit within the
program's main cases it's very similar
to a doubtless case at the end of an
infinite chain now why are these
statements so useful well many times
programmers want their programs to
function differently depending on
different conditions for instance a
program could function differently
depending on the information that the
user inputs such as allowing user to use
a program or not use a program if they
are above or below 18 years old
respectively or in say a video game if
the users experience is above a certain
threshold we might want to get them
harder a punch to battle another example
could be a program which changes the
color scheme depending on the time of
day or even more simply if a user
presses a button that is meant to move
on to another screen in an app the
programmer would only want that app to
change screens if the user clicks that
button a program without conditional
statements will do the same thing every
time and would be very primitive
compared to one that can change
depending on conditions so now that we
know how to make and use variables how
to compare them and what we can do with
those comparisons let's move on to
another foundational concept of computer
science and that is arrays now we've
already talked about variables and how
great they are for storing singular bits
of information for making our code more
simplistic but one of the biggest
drawbacks that comes with variables is
their inability to hold more than one
piece of differing information for
example let's say you're making an app
which allows a user to create a grocery
list well there's no real easy way to
create lists using variables because
it's not like you can have one variable
store the names of 6 or 7 different food
items remember we can only put one piece
of paper in our cardboard box no more
and besides even if you were able to add
multiple items to one string variable
you would still have a lot of trouble
doing simple tasks you might want from a
list such as searching through it
splitting it or even deleting items from
the list when you're done with them
this is the problem that using arrays
solves for us an array is as you may
have guessed by now a list you can have
an array of integers an array of strings
and even an array of other arrays which
is something we'll cover in a minute
programmers use arrays when they want to
store a lot of variables containing
information that is all related to each
other such as a grocery list or a high
score list in a game think of arrays is
a column in Excel or Google sheets you
have the title at the top and then below
it are a bunch of bits of information
which all relate back to the title
arrays are super useful when programmers
want to store a lot of information that
can be easily searched through because
programmers have developed methods of
breaking down and using a race to find
specific information and arrays full of
thousands of different variables I have
an example to show just how useful
arrays are let's say you're a startup
company that owns an app that has a
hundred thousand users every time a user
wants to create a new account they input
the username they want and then your
program will have to check to make sure
the account name hasn't already been
taken doing this requires you to search
through the information of all 100,000
of your users to see if that username
has it account with your service an
array would be able to contain all of
this information and make it easy to
search through and find out if the
account name has already been taken with
little to no delay now the single most
important thing to note about arrays is
how you reference each element of the
array within them let's create a basic
array called numbers and inside of it
put the digits 1 through 10 now when we
want to refer to each cell in this array
we would call upon its index in index is
just a fancy way of saying that numbers
placed within the array now you would
think that the first integer in this
array would be the first index the
second would be the second index and so
on but that's simply not the case in
computer science programming languages
refer to the first cell as e0 with
element in the array this means that if
we were talking about our new array of
numbers we just made the number four
would actually be in the third index
five would be in the fourth and so on so
instead of starting our count from one
we start from zero it's extremely weird
confusing but it's one of those
programing quirks you're gonna have to
memorize and commit to memory if you
were to not follow this nomenclature and
refer to the last element in this
as the 10th you get what is referred to
as in a ray out-of-bounds error since
you're trying to reference the 10th
element but there is no tenth element or
you're actually trying to do is
reference the ninth element another
extremely important thing to note about
arrays has to do with their size when
you initialize an array you can do it at
either one of two ways you can either
populate it with the elements that you
want contained in the array right then
and there creating and filling the array
at the same time or you can define how
many elements you want the array to hold
essentially the arrays size and then
populate it with elements later
this is because when we initialize an
array it creates a space in memory that
has the size of exactly what you give it
no more and no less this is great for
when we want to access elements in the
array because we can do so
instantaneously because the computer
knows exactly where in memory the array
is stored but the one downside is that
we can't increase the size of the array
later on all array sizes are final think
of this like setting up a bookshelf with
books by populating a bookshelf with a
certain number of books and then moving
on and filling the next shelf with
different books we have no way to go
back and add books to that first shelf
without shifting everything over once we
decide how much space to dedicate for an
array in this case there's no way to add
more space once again because this is
extremely important to remember this
means that once an array has been
defined there is no way to change the
size of it if you have an array titled
names with the size of 8 then you try to
add another name to the array you will
receive an error so be careful when
messing around with array sizes of
course you can always go back to the
start of your code when you initially
make the array and allocate more space
to it increasing its size if you find
out that you need more space to hold
items but once it's defined you cannot
change its size through conventional
methods another small thing I want to
touch upon really quickly is that when
you initialize an array you must
determine which type of our array it is
right then and there for example you
have to specifically say it will be an
array of strings or integers when
defining it and also you're not allowed
to mix and match meaning that you can't
have an array full of integers with a
few strings and some doubles
into the mix they all have to be the
same type now the last thing we're going
to cover on a race is a little funky and
that is the practice of putting a raise
inside of a raise if you make an array
of a raise it is referred to as a 2d or
two-dimensional array
think of these as matrices if you have
taken in the algebra class before now if
you haven't think back to our Google
sheets example but instead of using
columns we would add rows as well so now
each element in an array one simply just
be a string variable or an integer
variable but an entirely new array with
its own set of values and elements the
way we index these is mostly the same
except we would have two numbers two
index instead of one we start with the
row and then the column so a number in
the position zero two would be in the
first row three columns down in this
case the name Clint a number in the
position 1 1 would be two rows down and
two columns across in this case the name
Chris you get the idea now you can also
make three dimensional arrays by putting
an array inside of an array inside of an
array but that's a little above what
we're going to be covering so I'm going
to cut it off there next up we're going
to be talking about loops so what
exactly are loops next up we're going to
be talking about loops so what exactly
are loose next up we're going to be
talking about loops so what exactly are
loose next up we're going to be talking
about loops so what exactly are loops
next up we're going to be talking about
loops so what exactly are loose well as
you could probably tell by that
statement right there a programming loop
is a statement that is used to run
certain instructions repeatedly just
like how the opening statement of this
topic was repeated five times loops are
very useful for a variety of reasons for
instance imagine you want to print
something 15 times sure you could just
copy and paste the print statement 15
times but this is really annoying to
have to do it becomes even more
unrealistic when that number goes up to
say 100 or so now what if instead of
rewriting the same instructions over and
over again you would simply place the
print statement inside of a loop and it
will occur as many times as you were
like now that's the power of loops with
groups were able to repeat parts of code
multiple times now there are three
different types of loops that we'll be
discussing today and that first is the
for loop a for loop is very useful for
situations like the one described above
where you would like to carry out a
certain set of
structions to numerous times the syntax
for a for-loop varies depending on the
language however it usually consists of
three parts an integer value a condition
which the integer value must meet in
order to exit the loop and an operation
to modify the integer value at the
instructions inside of the loop are
completed each time the for loop runs
the operation you said will be performed
on the integer as long as that integer
still meets the condition you set
usually being greater than or less than
a constant value the for loop will
continue to run eventually when the
integer has been modified by either
increasing or decreasing it to the point
where no longer meets the condition the
for loop will terminate and the code
will continue to run for example the
Sarah integer value is I and we set it
equal to zero then we set the
conditional statement as I being less
than three so basically we're saying
that as long as I the variable we just
created is less than three continue
running the instructions contained
within the loop finally we make the
operation I plus plus meaning each time
the loop runs we don't increase it by
one and inside of the loop let's just
put a simple print statement now let's
run through the for loop we start with I
equals zero zero is less than three so
we enter the loop and print out hello
world now that the instructions are done
we add one two I'm making it one moving
on one is again less than three so we
want to get into the loop and print out
hello world again we had one two I'm
making it two now two is still less than
three so we enter the loop again in
print out hello world finally we add one
to it once again and it becomes 3 3 is
not less than 3 though it is equal to 3
and so we don't enter the loop and it
terminates moving on to the next segment
of code this is a simple example but you
can extrapolate it across the
programming to fit your needs now we're
using a for loop you have to make sure
to set up a condition that given the
initial integer value and operation well
at some point not be met to avoid
creating an infinite loop and crashing
your program an infinite loop occurs
when you give a for loop condition which
will always be met given the parameters
of the program and so the software it
crashes for example a for loop beginning
at 10 and checking if I is over less
than 0 and then adding 1 to I at the end
of the loop will never terminate since I
will suggest increase infinitely after
the for loop is the very similar for
each loop a for each loop or a for in a
list loop in Python is used for
iterating through arrays or lists
essentially though we will go through
each element in the
Raye and carry out some set of
instructions for each value if you would
like to read all of the elements in an
array and compare them to some value or
perform some operation on them a for
each loop is extremely useful so for
example we could have a for each loop
which iterated across an array and
simply printed out the value of each
array location next up we have the while
loop a while loop will continually carry
out its instructions while conditional
statement given to it is true this can
be as long as a certain variable is true
as long as it numbers less than another
number or while a value still equal to
another value for example while loops
are different than for loops in that the
loop is not contained within one
statement but stretched out and will
continue to run as long as this
condition is true like a for loop you
could make the condition such that it
will eventually return false and exit
the loop however while loops will not
crash your computer should you create an
infinite loop in fact it is very common
for while loops to run infinitely as for
certain programs you would like the
program to continually be iterated
through instead of running once all the
way through until you exit out of the
program when programming a game for
instance a while loop would be used to
iterate through your code continually
refreshing the screen as the game runs
from there you could perform operations
on the screen to make the game playable
creating an infinite while loop could be
done by simply using the syntax while if
true as the condition true will always
be evaluated as true finally I'd quickly
like to cover the extension of a while
loop the dowhile loop do-while loops are
very similar to while loops except they
will carry out their instructions at
least once even if the condition is
false and then will carry on like a
basic while loop essentially the
conditions inside of the loop will run
at least once and then if the condition
is still met they will run again and
function as normal while loop would as
you can see loops in there many
varieties has some extremely useful
functions using them if you are able to
perform an operation many times in a row
you can iterate through arrays and lists
and overall decrease the clutter of your
code
next up we're going to be taking a break
from learning about common programming
statements and dive into what happens
when the code we write doesn't work more
specifically we'll be covering the
different types of errors that can occur
when you're programming and what causes
them now when you're writing code you
have to understand that things aren't
always going to go the way you expected
them to and sometimes the program
doesn't always work as you hadn't
intended it to
we programmers call these errors and
while annoying they're always going to
come up in computer science and so it's
best to learn what they are and how to
deal with them often referred to as bugs
errors and scripting languages can be
narrowed down to one of three types
syntax errors runtime errors and logical
be covering in today's video to kick
things off let's talk about syntax
errors these are usually the easiest of
the three to solve since they are
oftentimes something that can be fixed
within seconds if you remember back to
earlier in the video when we talked
about syntax and programming rules we
said that if you were to break the
programming rules or syntax that it
would result in an error well that's
what syntax errors are parts in your
program where you fail to meet the
programming rules and so the computer
doesn't know how to interpret your code
this can be anything from forgetting a
semicolon at the end of a statement in
Java accidentally defining a variable
with two words instead of one or even
just misspelling the word string when
you're trying to define a string
variable lucky for you guys these errors
are extremely easy to fix since you just
need to figure out where the error
occurred and what the syntax rule you
broke was now thinking back to IDE s we
mentioned that ideas are so useful
because they do precisely that they
underline the syntax errors and usually
provide helpful hints as to how to fix
them think of syntax errors as small
misspellings or grammatical errors in an
essay you're writing annoying yes but
not the most infuriating things another
useful thing about IDE s when it comes
to syntax errors is that the program
will actually restrict you from running
the code unless all syntax errors are
cleared making them even easier to
identify and fix the second type of
error we will be covering is the runtime
error these errors don't show until you
actually run the code hence the name
runtime error runtime errors are usually
caused by statement in your code
that seems logically sound but the
computer physically has no way of
computing it in a reasonable amount of
time the most common of these errors is
one which we've already talked about the
infinite loop as a refresher or an
example think of an infinite loop like
this set u s-- at your friend down in
front of the TV put all in the office
and told him he could leave as soon as
michael made it that's what she said
joke seems pretty simple right wrong
because instead of putting in the office
you put in friends on blu-ray no Michael
no inappropriate joke meaning your
friend would be sitting there for the
rest of his life this is basically what
happens with the computer you give it
some condition that it has to complete
before the program can terminate however
you give it no fees a little way to
finish the task this puts the computer
in error mode and most likely it will
crash your program as the computer
desperately tries to complete the
condition you gave it as a computer
example if we try to have a program
terminate when integer AI is no longer
greater than 99 but AI is initially 100
and only ever increases the loop will
never terminate and the program will
crash to avoid these you generally want
to think through the flow of your code
before running it especially with loops
to make sure that all of your statements
can be completed by the computer
carefully planning out your code before
you begin writing is an extremely useful
practice and something we'll be covering
towards the later part of this video the
final type of error that we will be
covering is a logic error this error is
also pretty self-explanatory a logic
error occurs when the code runs smoothly
without any runtime or syntax errors but
the result that you get just isn't what
you wanted for example let's say you had
a calculator app and you wanted to
instruct the program to add two numbers
except it multiplied them because you
use the multiplication symbol on
accident this leads to the sum being 36
instead of 13 nothing went wrong with
the code syntax or runtime wise the code
runs just fine it just doesn't work as
you had and it headed it - these are
often the hardest types of errors to
debug since most of the time you'll have
no idea why the code isn't working and
certainly not any idea of how to fix it
this is why it's a good idea to test
your code incrementally
don't wait until you've been programming
for an hour before testing your
application where else you'll run into a
lot of logic errors logic errors can be
extremely Fury aiding and could cost you
a lot of time making them a huge pain
but if you know how to effectively debug
your code you'll be just fine
speaking of debugging your code that
brings just straight into our next topic
which is how to debug your program now
let's say you've written a program you
think it's ready
and you're ready to test it you've been
working hard on this and you're deciding
to see it in action you run the program
and wait for it to run smoothly and
efficiently only it doesn't work you've
encountered one of the three errors
we've just mentioned you really want
this code to work but how this is where
debugging comes into play if the code is
giving you an error and the first thing
you should do is read the error
oftentimes for syntax and runtime errors
the IDE will print an error message out
to the console see what line or lines it
points to since those little lines at
the error occurred and see if you can
understand and fix what the problem is
if the error isn't clear or you've never
heard of it then try googling it as
there are many websites out there such
as stack overflow which service forums
to ask and answer problems with code
chances are if you've had a problem
someone else's have the same issue and
there's likely a tested solution usually
when the syntax or a runtime error pops
up you should be able to find a fix for
it fairly easily however as I said
before the issue may arise from some
loophole or oversight in the code you
hadn't planned forward beforehand maybe
you did something as simple as multiply
two variables instead of adding them
these are logic errors we talked about
previously these problems usually won't
have Fred Tex show up to explain what
went wrong you'll have to figure it out
yourself
now there are a few different strategies
that you can use in order to track down
and fix a logic error first you could
use print statements and the console in
order to determine where the code is
going wrong imagine you have a
conditional statement that will run one
segment of code if an integer X is
greater than 5 and will run another
segment of code if not if in your
program X is supposed to be greater than
5 when the program reaches this
conditional but for some reason the
program is still printing out X is small
you can use the prints they meant to
help for this problem specifically you
could place the print statement before
the branch of the conditional that
print the value of X now when you run
the program you know exactly what the
computer is thinking printing out the
value of X just before the if-else
statement well you know if the variable
has the value you wanted to have and if
it doesn't you know that somewhere above
that conditional something went wrong
and X was set to a value you didn't want
it to in this case X is equal to 2 which
is why X is small is being printed out
now that we know what the problem is we
can track down where and when in the
code we modify X in order to solve it
use print statements to determine where
your program goes wrong and then try to
track down the cause of these issues and
solve them if you use this strategy make
sure you end up deleting the print
statements afterwards to avoid clutter
in the console the situation described
above could also be solved using a break
point a break point pauses your program
when the line you place the breakpoint
at is reached if say you would like the
program to run through a certain
conditional and set a variable based on
that conditional but you are unsure if
this actually happens in your code you
can place a breakpoint inside the
conditional path that you expect to run
upon the breakpoint being reached the
program will pause and wait for you to
continue it through a button press this
signals the spot in the code where the
breakpoint was placed in this case the
correct conditional path has been
reached by your program you can then
continue the program knowing that this
was or wasn't where the error in your
code occurred breakpoints can be used in
conjunction with print statements in
order to both pause the program and
perhaps view the values of your
variables at the moment in time to give
yourself all the information you could
want you can also have multiple
breakpoints to help slowly work your way
through your program and determine where
an error has occurred a combination of
these two strategies will help you
easily determine where in your code you
have incurred a logic error next let's
go over what to do if you think you have
tracked down the section of code that
causes the problem you may think you
should delete it but it's likely you put
it there for a reason and you don't want
to lose all that work if you don't have
to firstly try commenting it out
comments are used to mark up code and
explain their surrounding sections they
can also be used to debug anything that
is designated as a comment will not be
read by the program as code and will be
skipped over essentially it becomes
something that is only there for you the
programmer to read
the syntax varies from language to
language but it usually involves placing
some symbols before or around the code
you would like to be commented examples
of how to comment in different languages
can be seen on the screen now also when
you comment something the IDE will
grayscale that line of code making it
extremely easy to determine what's
commented and what's not commenting code
deletes it in the computer's eyes
without actually deleting it if a
problem is present before you come in a
section of code but it has gone
afterwards in that section of codes the
culprit if you comment part of the code
out and there are still issues and move
on to another section until you find the
culprit once you do you can tweak it
until it works as intended or delete it
entirely and you'll have a fully
functioning program once again now that
we've talked about what to do if you've
encountered an error and its strategy on
how to find and fix it I'd like to talk
about some strategies you can use to
avoid errors in the first place firstly
back of your code frequently in the
event of the code completely bugging out
and you being unable to fix it you will
want the ability to revert to a previous
version where the code was still working
if you save frequently enough then you
will probably not lose too much work
version managers like github or
subversion can help with this as they
backup code to an online cloud surface
in which you can easily pull previous
versions of the program from at any
point also on top of saving running a
program frequently to ensure that the
current version works as intended this
accomplishes two things first of all it
prevents you from saving a backup that
doesn't work secondly if you encounter a
problem it will be easier to find if you
have only made a small number of changes
since the last time you ran and it
worked and thus you will only have to
look through the new code for problems
if you've spent five hours coding and
hadn't run it during that time period
it's going to be likely that at some
point during that five our code session
you messed up and it's going to be even
harder to figure out where you went
wrong errors while annoying an extremely
frustrating
our fundamental part of making you a
better programmer alright now that we've
covered errors for a bit let's hop back
on the programming statement train and
talk about one of the most important
concepts in computer science
they'll function now you may not know it
but we've actually been talking about a
few functions this entire series print
statements for loops and even the basic
math operations we've talked about are
all examples of
functions which of course begs the
question of what actually defines a
function well a function is a segment of
code that can be easily run by calling
the function name and depending on the
type of function will do something in
return functions can be called numerous
times and in numerous places in your
code essentially they are like wrapping
up a segment of code into a nice present
and giving it a name which when called
will unwrap the present and go through
the code that you'd wrapped up for
example the print statements we've been
using this series allow us to print
something to the console anytime we want
those are functions you see we just call
the print function and enter in what we
want to be printed to the console into
the parenthesis and the computer does it
for us behind the scenes there's
actually even more complex code that is
in charge of taking your text and
translating it to the console to be
printed the developers of almost all
programming languages realize that you
don't want to program something that
manually has to print something to the
console through the use of complex
programming and so they implemented the
print statement to reduce the stress and
complexity of code on the user
abstracting it to the single line of
code that is print all of that code that
is used to print something to the
console is wrapped up like a present and
given to us in the form of one line this
is actually the main theme of all
functions and the backbone of any good
program often times in your program
they're going to be sections of code
which are repeated and serve the same
purpose or equations which you want to
allow differing inputs of and so you can
use functions in order to condense these
down into singular lines of code to save
both time and reduce clutter on your
code as you will see soon functions are
extremely powerful and will definitely
be something you utilize all the time in
your computer science journey the print
statement is just one example of
functions in everyday code there are
thousands of function that are available
to you through the IDE s however because
we won't always use all the functions
that are available to you in a single
program you have to import these
functions from packages found in the IDE
which is something that we'll be
covering later on now there are four
main types of functions in most
programming languages and they
separated by two defining features
whether or not they take in arguments
and whether or not they return values
let's start by separating them by
whether or not they take arguments but
first we have to cover what arguments
actually are arguments are essentially
variables that we pass into the function
in order to be manipulated and then
either return back to us printed to the
console or used in another operation
think of functions with arguments like
this if you walked up to your local five
guys and told them that you wanted to
get food without supplying a type of
food they would probably look at you
confused in order to get the food that
you want you need to tell them exactly
what you want to order so that they can
give it to you in this case getting food
is the function and what you order in
terms of food is being passed in as the
argument based on what you tell them or
the argument that you pass into the get
food function they will do something
different you should also note that the
argument can be many different things it
could be fries burgers sodas really
anything on the menu and such as the
case with arguments and programming
arguments can be strings integers arrays
pretty much anything as an example of a
function that takes in arguments let's
look at the max function which takes in
two integers as arguments and returns
the maximum number between the two now
for this function if you don't input two
numbers or variables for it to compare
it's going to throw you an error just
like the five guys employee he doesn't
know what you want to eat since you
didn't provide him with any arguments
and the computer doesn't know which two
numbers you wanted to compare and
returned since you didn't provide it
with two integers arguments are a way
for programmers to have one function
that can do many different things
depending on whichever variables can be
passed through arguments add variability
of programming and can help diversify
your code think of it like this a
restaurant that only allows one type of
food to be made regardless of what you
order isn't going to be very useful or
diversified but if we're able to pass in
arguments and tell them what food we
want our experience can be heightened
and more options can become available to
us which is exactly what happens when
you start using arguments in your
function
now that we've talked about functions
that take in arguments let's move on to
functions which do not because functions
can also be created and used without
taking arguments in and still be
incredibly useful to the programmer for
example let's say you are making a
text-based RPG game and one of the
options you give your player is the
ability to view their stats at various
points throughout the game now every
time you come upon this option and they
choose the view stats button you don't
have to type out six different print
statements for every statistic they may
have your code would get cluttered and
messy very quickly instead what you
could do is you could package the six
different print statements in a simple
function called print stats you don't
need to pass in any arguments into the
function since the function will do the
same thing no matter what the statistics
on the player are now every time the
user wants to view their stats you could
simply call the print stats function and
voila the user stats are printed for
them to view this allows you to save a
lot of time writing code but also a lot
of space which is extremely important
when your programs begin getting into
hundreds and thousands of lines of code
and you want to easily search through it
to maybe
debug okay now that we've separated
functions into those that take arguments
and those that do not let's again split
these up into those that return values
and those that do not another thing you
have to understand is that when you're
making your own functions which is
something that we'll be covering very
soon you have to choose what your
function will return if anything at all
functions are able to return values back
to the user whether they be in the form
of string variables integer variables or
even arrays now the thing to note about
returning variables is that calling the
function alone won't do anything you
have to return the value into something
or print it out as an example the max
function we talked about previously
would return an integer back to the user
but in order to do something with it
we would have to either set a new
integer variable equal to the result of
that max function or we can print out
the result of the function which in this
case which is print out the maximum
value between the two integers using
functions which return values don't do
much on their own you have to pair it
with
thing in order to gain the use from it
let's do another example let's say you
had created a function which took in two
string variables as arguments and
combined that using that fancy string
math we talked about earlier and then
returned them as a singular string this
combined string function could then be
used to create new string variables
since what it returns is basically a
string the variable would simply be set
to whatever is returned from this
combined string function the last type
of function is one that does not return
anything and these are known as void
functions oftentimes these are like the
print stat functions that we created
earlier simply use to condense large
amounts of print statements that appear
often in your code these can not be set
to variables since they don't return
anything and just get the code that's
within them run through so there you
have it the four types of functions ones
that taking arguments and return
something ones that take in arguments
and don't return something ones that
don't take in arguments but still return
values and ones that take in arguments
and don't return anything each of these
four types of functions are useful and
unique in their own way and you will
probably find yourself using each of
them through your programming journey so
get used to the different types of
functions and know how to make the most
of them as they are all extremely
powerful finally I'd like to talk about
one of the major benefits of functions
which is that it makes it super useful
to make large changes to your code
without having to go through the entire
program each function call is
essentially just a copy of that
functions original code and so it's very
easy to make changes to that initial
function and have a translate across
your entire code let's go back to our
print stats function and say that you
wanted to go back and add in a new
statistic that the player could level up
and through experience in the game
without functions you would have to go
back into your code and find every
instance that you'd printed out the user
stats and create another print statement
to display the new statistic however if
you had created a print stats function
like we did just a Lyle go all you would
need to do is find out where you define
that function and add in a print
statement which displays the new
statistic and you're done
now every place which you had previously
called the print stats function will now
also print the new statistic as well you
can see just how powerful functions can
be if used properly and we haven't even
scratched the surface yet now up next
we're going to cover how we can import
other people's functions that they've
written and use them in our code now
before we get technical close your eyes
and imagine you are trying to build a
house sure you could grow your own trees
chop down your own wood make your own
tools and nails and vote from scratch
but why do that when you can simply go
to your local Home Depot and buy these
materials that others have already made
ready for you that's the main idea
behind importing functions into your
code importing functions allows you to
gain access to libraries of functions
that other people have already made for
you this is just as useful as it sounds
there are so many functions that are
super useful for any given program that
it will take you forever to write them
all yourself
luckily other people already done most
of this for you in each programming
language you were able to use an import
statement to import libraries of
functions into your program that you can
use as you write it a library is simply
a collection of functions that all have
the same theme and maybe a math library
a data analysis library a library which
translates text or anything you can
think of really there's such a variety
of libraries for any given language that
most functions you require that are not
hyper specific to your program can
likely be found in some library in fact
a good portion of any programmers job is
looking online for packages which can
make his or her job easier instead of
hand writing functions now I can hear
you saying wow that's sick how do I do
it well it's quite simple an import
statement in most languages an import
statement consists of three parts the
library you would like to import from
the package you would like to import
from that library and then which class
from that package you would like to use
for example we can load up the Java
library and from there import the you
tow package short for utilities and then
from that utilities package import the
scanner class a class which allows us to
read information from the user a package
is simply a smaller sect of functions
and methods to help differentiate
the thousands of methods contained in a
library and a class is even more
specialized than that now if you don't
know what specific classes you're going
to want to pull methods from you can use
a start import all classes within the
package you like however it can be
beneficial to be more specific and only
import the classes you would like as it
helps with the efficiency of the program
in the long run for instance in Python
the syntax to import a library is import
followed by the library name
however importing an entire library is
more computationally taxing than
importing specific functions from a
library imagine you would only be using
the factorial function from the Python
math library it would be a waste of
computing power to import the entire
library and it would increase the load
time for your program for smaller
programs this isn't a big deal
but it really starts to add up when
dealing with larger projects therefore
you would instead use from math import
factorial or the Java equivalent import
Java math factorial and now have access
to that one math command only this
limits the functions that you can use
however it saves programming runtime if
you decide you want to use another
function that you hadn't planned for you
can always go back and import that too
many times if you try to use a function
from a common package and you have not
yet imported it the IDE will prompt you
to do so if you're trying to figure out
which libraries you want to import think
what the functions you're going to need
in your program perform a simple google
search and you will probably run into a
package or library that already exists
in your IDE that you can use and if you
can't there are ways to download and
import additional projects to fit your
needs
but what if after all that you still
can't find a library that contains the
function you're looking for well that's
a perfect segue into what we're going to
talk about next which is the basic
structure for writing your own functions
so at this point we've talked about both
what functions are and how we can get
some very useful functions by importing
them through packages but they're
definitely going to be moments in your
programming career where you're going to
want to make your own functions because
you won't want to be made specifically
to your program and code
luckily making your own functions is
extremely simple there are just some
basic rules that I want to cover now
well we've previously used making
functions as an example for other topics
such as the player stats function from a
little bit ago they were extremely
abstract and didn't go into depth into
what is needed for an actual function to
operate so right now we're going to be
covering a skeletal system of everything
that needs to be included in a function
in order to get it to work now think
back to the four different types of
functions that we talked about
previously functions that do and don't
return values and functions that both do
and don't take in arguments for creating
your own functions we're just going to
have to go down the list and talk about
how to approach creating each one of
them starting with the most basic of the
bunch one which takes in no arguments
and returns no values but before we
start that there are a few small things
I want to note about function naming
conventions the variable naming
conventions we talked about previously
also translate over to function names so
you can't have two word functions and
you can't use special characters like
periods or commas generally you're going
to want to follow the sames camelcase
style which we talked about in the
variables video which is not
capitalizing the first word but
capitalizing each word after that
alright so in general for making
functions each language differentiates
on how you tell the computer that it's
actually a function in java you have to
define the function scope which is
something you don't really need to know
unless you're going to become more
invested in java but basically it tells
the computer which parts of the code can
use the function in which type can for
this series all of our functions that we
make are going to be public from there
you then determine which type of
function it is so in this case since it
won't be returning any variables we'll
just put void to signify this type of
function will not be returning anything
finally you put the function name after
those two identifiers along with a set
of parentheses after it like so
the parentheses are where your arguments
would go if you were making a function
that took in arguments but since for our
first type of function we're not
incorporating arguments into this
function let's just leave those blank
all of that is just for Java Python on
the other hand all you have to do is put
the word def short for define and then
the function name with a set of
parentheses so as you can see each
language is going to be a little bit
different in how you make functions but
the main thing we want to remember is to
always add parentheses from there we
just type what we want our void function
to do within the confines of the
function and close it off and we're done
in Java the confines of the loop would
be whatever is contained within the
curly braces and in Python it would be
until you are no longer indented at its
core this is the most primitive type of
function we've made something which
takes in no arguments and returns no
values quite similar to the print stats
function from early on moving on to the
next type of function creating a void
function that takes in arguments now
this process is going to seem very
similar to the previous except for one
small adjustment remember the
parentheses that I mentioned earlier
well we put any variables we want the
user to pass into the function into
these parentheses and then when we call
that specific function it will be
required to have those variables passed
into it for example in Java let's make a
function that takes in two numbers and
prints out the product of those numbers
we start with the public void plus name
a function set up again since we won't
be returning any values and here comes a
new part inside the parentheses you
define which type of variables you would
like to pass in as arguments in this
case an integer and then a name for that
variable this name is what you will use
to refer to the integer that the user
passes in for example let's just call it
num1 then if we want to add another
argument we simply add a comma in
between the two and we can make another
integer variable num 2 to hold the
second number we could do this for
however many variables we want to pass
into the function but for now let's
close off the parentheses and just print
out the product of num1 and num2 as you
can see we refer to the two numbers that
the
user will input into the function as
num1 and num2 whatever numbers that the
user passes into the function will be
converted into num1 and num2 now
whenever we want to call the multiply
numbers function we just have to make
sure that we are putting two numbers in
as arguments in this case the number 5
becomes num1 and the number 8 becomes
num2 from there we simply run the code
and the number 40 is printed to the
console it's pretty important to note
that you can also mix and match
variables when making arguments so you
can have some function which takes in a
car an integer and two strings all
within one function the last thing I
want to mention about arguments is that
when you call a function you have to
follow the variables you defined when
making the function so for our multiply
numbers function you couldn't put in a
string and then an int it has to be two
integers because that's what the
computer is expecting to be passed into
the function so now that we've gone over
how to make functions that don't return
variables we have to cover those that do
and we'll start with ones that don't
take in arguments now the main
difference between defining functions
that return variables and defining ones
that do not is that in some cases you
have to specify that you want this
function to return an integer variable
this is most common in Java
where you would replace a void with int
to tell the computer that you want this
function to give you something back to
you in the form of an integer this works
the same as if you wanted to return a
string care or even in an array you
simply replace the word after public
with whatever variable you want to be
returned by that function the most
important thing to remember about making
functions that return variables is that
no matter what path your code takes it
must return a variable no matter what
what does this mean well let's say you
had some string function in a game and
inside of it there was an if statement
where if the player score was above 10
you returned two congratulatory message
this works fine if you printed the
result of this function and the player
scores above 10 but if the player score
was less than 10 then you don't enter
the if statement and then you don't have
something prepared to be returned to the
user and so the function is going to
throw you an error you have to have all
your paths cover
which may seem simple but if you're
making a function with a switch
statement in it containing high amounts
of cases then this can get out of hand
very quickly something I like to do to
make sure this doesn't happen is put a
return statement at the bottom of a
function with a string or an integer so
unique that I'm able to tell that the
code is not running properly and can fix
it also usually an IDE will let you know
if there's a path in your code or in a
function that does not return a variable
when it should the main point I'm trying
to get across however is always cover
your exits and make sure you have a
return statement prepared for any case
the user may throw at you another small
thing to note is that you can't return
one type of variable if you've already
defined the function to return another
type for example you can't return a
string and an integer function or
vice-versa the return statement must
always match the type of function no
matter what the final type of function
is one that returns variables and also
takes in arguments and for these all you
need to do is combine we've learned from
the previous cases first you assign your
arguments in between the parentheses
making sure that you have also defined
what type of variable you want to return
and then ensure that no matter what path
the code takes that you're always
returning that variable type that
concludes our discussion on functions as
you can probably tell functions are an
extremely vast subject area and require
a little bit of practice to fully
understand which is why later on in this
series will recommend some websites you
can use to practice those more difficult
topics
now I'd like to switch gears a little
bit and continue our discussion from
earlier on our arrays arrays while
useful aren't the only way to store and
manipulate information in fact there are
a multitude of different ways to store
data in computer science including
linked lists stacks queues maps trees
and many others too right now though I'd
like to talk about two cool wacky and
zany ways to store data that we haven't
previously covered array lists and
dictionaries but before we get into
those let's get a little review and
reinforcement of arrays as you may
remember arrays are basically lists of
values that are stored together when you
initialize an array you give it a size
and this size is fixed you won't be able
to increase the size of the array so
when you make an array it's length is
final
to access the values and an array you
reference them using an index four
starts at zero what this means is that
the first item of an array is not at
position one it is at position zero and
its position is commonly referred to as
its index location so to find the nth
item in an array you would refer to it
as index location n minus one however as
the size of an array is fixed you have
to be careful to not reference a
position that is beyond the total size
of the array or to append too many items
to it as this will return an error we
also have what are known as
two-dimensional arrays which is an array
containing an array in each of its
indexes or you could have an array
containing arrays containing arrays
containing arrays containing arrays
depending on what you're trying to do
multi-dimensional arrays can be useful
in more advanced programs for organizing
a wide volume of related values if
that's confusing at all just give back
to earlier for our full discussion on
arrays the time stamp will be in the
description now that we've reviewed
arrays let's go over array lists array
lists or just lists in Python can be
thought of as a growing array earlier we
mentioned how you have to be careful to
set an appropriate size of your array
and to make sure that you only reference
and up in value such that you remain
within the size however with array lists
this isn't a problem after you
initialize an array
it instinctively has the size of 10 but
if you append values such that the size
of the arraylists goes beyond 10
elements an array list will grow itself
meaning that the computer will allocate
more memory to the array to increase its
total size so that the new values can be
appended this is quite useful when you
don't know the exact number of values
that the array will need to store or you
want the ability to store more values to
your heart's content such as when you're
making a database with an unknown amount
of fusers that will sign up there is a
lot more to uncover when regarding a
write lists but for this surface-level
series that is all you pretty much need
to know so let's move on to dictionaries
now when we're talking about
dictionaries we're not referencing that
thick book you probably have lying
around your house which has thousands of
definitions in computer science
dictionaries are like arrays in that
they store multiple values however the
ragas are stored very differently rather
than being referenced by their linear
position within the dictionary each
value is tied to another value that is
used to reference it or it's key because
of this we need to throw away all
conceptions of dictionaries as a linear
way of looking at data since in
actuality it is much more fluid than
interchanging basically we say that each
position in a dictionary holds a key
value pair when referencing a value in a
dictionary you would use its unique key
and the dictionary will tell you the
value that it is tied to think of it
like this each time you add an item to
your dictionary your computer creates a
handcrafted box to store the data and
also a custom makes a jewel key
one-of-a-kind no other like in the world
this way there is only one key that goes
to the box that stores a certain bit of
information because each key must be
unique we're using the key in a
dictionary it will result in an error
being thrown because having two keys
that are exactly the same would confuse
the computer as to what box or piece of
information that key leads to however
you can store the same value in multiple
key value pairs since the keys would all
be different now like I said
dictionaries are more fluid making them
easier to organize than arrays as
everything is set up in a more logical
manner that is to say it is easier to
find the value you are looking for when
you're using keys rather than simply
referencing their positions let me
explain what I mean
imagine you have a dictionary of prices
at a store where the key is the name of
the product and the value is the price
of the item
maybe apples cost $1 mil costs $2 and
bread costs $3 you can see that in the
dictionary each key is the name of a
product and each value corresponds to
the price of each product so to find the
price of bread
all you need to do is simply call the
dictionary using the key bread this
makes it extremely easy to track values
through your code since you're working
with tangible values rather than numbers
which don't mean anything to you you can
also manipulate dictionaries and many of
the same ways you can manipulate arrays
and array lists you can iterate through
a dictionary and perform many operations
and comparisons on the values if you
want to find the product with the
highest price for example you can
iterate through the dictionary to find
the value that is highest amongst the
grocery store items arrays array lists
and dictionaries are useful in their own
right as are the mass amounts of other
ways to store data and each post certain
advantages over one another we already
covered the basics of these three but
since there are so many we don't have
time to go in-depth into each and every
one of them and so in order to help you
grasp the basics of storing information
we're now going to talk about one of the
most important functions needed to
understand arrays which are searching
algorithms now just as there are many
ways to store information in computer
science there are even more ways of
searching through lists searching
algorithms at their core are ways in
which we can look through a list of
values stored in an array say a patient
name list or a high score list and find
a particular piece of data the goal of a
searching algorithm is simply to give
the algorithm a string or object you
want it to find and have it return the
index of the array that contains that
string or object as fast as possible now
while this may seem simple lots of
software runs on the backbone of being
able to search through lists extremely
quickly making searching algorithms and
in particular efficient searching
algorithms an important topic to cover
additionally this is the main
functionality that arrays are used for
and it's the backbone of many of the
methods used within array lists as well
as many other storage methods so knowing
them will take you a very long way
typically searching algorithms are used
to return the index of a particular data
point so that it can be used modify
I updated or checked on for example if
you're about to check into a hospital
run on an array system for patients the
staff must search through your name and
at the database and by returning index
of where your name is
they now have a quantifiable number that
they can use to easily check you in rent
out prescriptions schedule you for
checkups update your personal
information etc without having to search
through the list for your name every
single time you may think that there's
little difference between searching
algorithms since computers nowadays can
perform millions of calculations per
second but when you're a huge multi
billion dollar corporation trying to
find a certain data point in a list
containing thousands or even millions of
data points small differences in
efficiency are going to make or break
the user experience even a 1%
improvement in efficiency can mean a big
differences in the amount of time that a
user is waiting for a simple task now
Before we jump into different types of
searching algorithms we must discern
between the two states that a razor list
can be in either sorted or unsorted a
sorted list of information is
characterized by some sort of rank able
value whether that be a patient ID
credit card number or even by
alphabetical values like usernames or
legal names an unsorted list is just
some random assortment of related
information not sorted by any particular
order or reason some searching
algorithms only work for sorted lists
usually the more efficient ones and some
work for both sorted and unsorted lists
although these are usually less
efficient if you end up pursuing
computer science further you'll have to
deal with both sorted and unsorted lists
so it's good to know a common searching
practice for both another thing to note
is that we would determine the
efficiency of searching algorithms based
on both the worst case scenario and the
average number of items that must search
in order to find the index we call this
Big O notation in which each searching
algorithm has an equation which takes in
the size of the array as an integer N
and will output a worst case scenario
efficiency value that we can use to
compare with other searching algorithms
we can then also look at how long on
average it takes to find an element in a
list using these two methods allows us
to easily compare how efficient two
algorithms
all right now that we've got some
background on searching algorithms let's
hop right into it the first type of
search we'll be talking about is called
a linear search and Eve honestly
probably uses multiple times throughout
your life every time you have to search
for your name on a list of people you
probably follow the same pattern you
start at the top check to see if the
first name on the list is yours if it is
great if not you move on to the next
name on the list until either you find
your name or you don't in which case you
leave a linear search works in the same
way you start with the first element in
the list compared to the value that
you're trying to find and if they're the
same you found your match and you return
the index of that element and if not you
move on to the next element in the list
until you either find the thing you're
searching for where you run out of lists
to check
pretty simple right this is because
linear searches are pretty bad when it
comes to efficiency especially in the
worst case scenario if the item you're
searching for in the list is the last
element you're going to have to check
the entire list of items before you find
the one you're searching for on average
however you're going to get it about
halfway through the list
this makes the linear search o of n
worst case scenario since in the worst
possible case it will take the entire
length of the array or n to find the
correct value the linear search on
average will return the correct index in
oh of n divided by two we're halfway
through the list
now while the linear search isn't great
it can work with both sorted and
unsorted lists because of the fact that
it will eventually cover every element
in the list the other search we're going
to cover requires the list to be sorted
which may seem like a drawback but
having a sorted list allows you to use
algorithms that are far more efficient
than the linear search so overall the
linear search is a good basic searching
algorithm before if you have an unsorted
list but if your list is sorted there
are way more efficient options out there
for you such as the binary search which
we'll be talking about now the binary
search uses a recursive process to break
the data in your list down into more and
more manageable bites taking advantage
of the fact that it's sorted in order to
find the item you're looking for faster
this one is much harder to wrap your
head around so let's start with an
example
let's say you have a list of 10 names
sorted alphabetically like shown on the
screen now and you wanted to find your
name within that list in binary search
you would look for the middlemost name
in this case the one at the 4th index
just a quick aside since there is no
true middle since the list is ten names
long the computer automatically uses the
next one down as the middle value now
once you find your middle value you
first check to see if the name you're
searching for at the index you've chosen
is the name that you're looking for if
it is you simply return that index but
99% of the time it's not going to be
including right now so let's keep going
if the value at the middle name is not
equal to the one you're searching for
you check to see if the value you're
searching for comes before or after the
middle index for example if you were
looking for the name Brendan and the
value at the middle index was Carl
Brendan obviously comes before Carl
alphabetically and since we know that
the list is sorted what we can now do is
ignore the entire bottom half of the
list and just focus on the top since we
know that if Brendan is even in the list
it's going to be in that top half now we
simply treat the top half of the list as
an entirely new entity and repeat the
process over again again we would find
the middlemost
element of this new list of names and
again compared to the name you're trying
to find if it's the name we're trying to
find we return that index but if not we
compare it to see if it comes before or
after the middle index going back to our
example let's say the middle index of
this new list is AJ now we know that
Brendan comes after AJ alphabetically so
what we can now do is ignore the top
have the list since we know that if
Brendan is in the list it's not going to
be in the top half of our list now we
again repeat this process again and
again until we find the name when you're
looking for so for our example the
middle index is time is Brendan and
that's what we're searching for so
finally we would return the index to in
binary search
eventually the index we were compared to
our search term will be the same and
once it is we can return the index and
move on now if we don't find it
which happens after we have eliminated
the entirety of the list without finding
our search term the algorithm will
simply return a no value to let you know
that the item you're searching for
cannot be found in the list
the binary search is way faster and more
efficient than the linear search
since we are drastically cutting down
the amount of elements we have to look
at making the program run faster in
almost 99.9% of cases in which your list
is sorted the binary search is going to
return a result faster than the linear
search so if you have a sorted list your
best option is to go for binary as for
efficiency the binary search is no log n
for the worst case scenario which could
be confusing if you don't fully
understand logarithms but all you need
to know is that it is way more efficient
than the linear search it's average
scenario is actually also o log n as
well which again is infinitely times
more efficient than the linear cases now
while there are other types of searching
algorithms you can use these two are the
most common for both unsorted and sorted
lists so we will stop there for now up
next we're going to be covering one of
the most confusing and important topics
in computer science recursion
let's start with the most important
question what exactly does recursion
mean in programming recursion refers to
functions that repeatedly call
themselves meaning that in the
instructions that occur within a
function one of the instructions will be
a call to that same function you're
already in in the extremely primitive
example on your screen now you can see
we have some function which in the
confines of itself calls itself a
recursive function will usually take
into account some integer as an argument
and we'll use this to carry out some
instructions modifying the integer that
was entered before calling itself again
with a new integer as its argument to
better understand these functions let's
discuss the basics of how we go about
programming one of them a really good
and easy example of a recursive function
is one which sums up all numbers from 1
to n so let's make a recursive function
that does just that the first thing we
need is the actual function and we're
going to make it an integer function
which takes an integer n as its argument
the reason we do this will be explained
later but for now let's move on to the
base case
a base case is simply a definite value
which all recursive statements the ones
that are being repeatedly called as we
go through the function try to get
towards at the be any of the function we
test a value that was passed in by the
argument against the base case to see if
it is satisfied usually these base cases
are some requirements like if n as I
described before which is a certain
value or is equal to a certain value it
is extremely important that the base
case is set to some requirement that n
will eventually meet for the same reason
that it is important to avoid an
infinite loop we do not want a stack
overflow error to occur for example if
our base case was to stop calling the
recursive function when n was greater
than 100 and if it is not we will call
the same function again but with n minus
1 and we started with n as say 99 we
would never reach the base case and the
recursive function will repeatedly call
itself over and over again subtracting 1
from N and hoping that somehow it will
eventually be greater than 100 until
your computer crashes not fall so
anyways back to our recursive some
example let's make our base case when n
is less than or equal to 1 this way we
can start at some positive integer n
and subtract from it until it is less
than or equal to one in which case we
can exit the recursive statement cool
now if n is not less than or equal to
one what we want to do is return the sum
of both N and then the returning value
of our recursive sum method
minus one why do we add and end the
function call well let's actually go
through the function as if we were the
computer and see why we start with a
call of recursive sum with N equals 3
we know that 3 is not less than or equal
to 1 so now we tried to return a
recursive sum of n which is 3 and the
returning value of recursive sum with an
N of 2 we don't know what the returning
value of recursive sum with an N of 2 is
so we have to go through the function
again only this time n is 2 again and is
not less than or equal to 1 and so this
function will go through the out
statement in return 2 plus another
recursive statement in this case the
returning value of recursive sum with an
N of 1 so once again we have to go
through the recursive sum function to
get that value that will be added to 2
and then returned and add it to 3 and
then return hanging in there we're
closed now in this function and is less
than or equal to 1 and so we return n
which is 1 now we take that n which
again is 1 and that is what gets added
to 2 in the previous function call and
then return so this would return 3 now
this 3 is what gets added to the first
function call which is 3 and so it
becomes 3 plus 3 which is 6 and finally
after all that time we get 6 return from
the function which if you've been
following along at home 3 plus 2 plus 1
is indeed 6 now this may seem like a
waste of time since 3 plus 2 plus 1 is
not a hard operation what did those of
you saying that I asked you to please
give me a sum of all the numbers from 1
to three thousand 567 Godspeed
now recursion is a very difficult
concept to wrap your head around so if
you're not 100% comfortable with it at
the moment
feel free to re-watch this section of
the video in order to better familiarize
yourself with it all right cool now that
we have a little background on recursion
let's talk about why it works so well
now to understand why and how recursion
works we must first understand what a
stack is a stack is a data structure
that contains all of the tasks you
instruct your program to complete based
on a certain method your program will
then carry out the tasks you give it
it's called a stack because if we start
another process before the previous one
completes the process is stacked on top
of the other one such as the animation
on your screen is showing now programs
we write will follow the leaf o
structure for those unfamiliar with the
counting leaf o means last in first out
or the last item put on the stack will
be the first one removed from it
essentially every time you ask your
computer to complete a task that task is
added to the stack and will be the first
one to be resolved think of it like a
stack of stones you can keep adding
stones on top of your pile but in order
to get to the one at the bottom you must
first remove all the rocks on top of it
now when your function continually calls
itself without end without a base case
like in our infinite loop example then
the stack will never be resolved as
items will be continually added to the
stack without any of them ever being
completed in this case the memory
allocated to the stack exceeds the
maximum allowed and a stack overflow
error occurs resulting in your program
crashing think of this as if you're
doing chores and before you complete one
chore you get called to do another chore
and then before you can complete that
one you get called to do another one
since you keep stacking tasks or shores
on top of one another the stack of tasks
will never be completed and you will
probably die before ever finishing all
of your chores this is the same logic
that makes infinite loops crash your
program recursion works on these same
principles the initial call makes a
second call which is added to the stack
and now that one must be taken care of
first but in that one another
function is called which gets added to
the stack and so on until you reach the
base case in which you slowly start
going back down the stack in conclusion
recursion in general is extremely useful
because by calling the same functions
repeatedly it breaks down the problem
into smaller sections and results in the
program being more efficient small parts
of problems are easier to solve and less
taxing to compute than the entire
problem at once and the computer can
combine these small solutions into the
whole solution at the end now as we wind
down our introduction to programming
series we want to take some time and go
over some of the soft skills needed to
be a successful computer scientist since
it's not all about writing code in fact
many professional computer scientists
will tell you that the majority of their
job is spent thinking about code
rather than actually writing it this is
because much of programming boils down
to problem solving how do we optimize
the system how can we make this feature
for our app what type of movement do we
want for our game and how can we program
it the harsh truth is that no good
program has ever been written simply
from the program are getting the prompt
or idea
sitting down hopping on an IDE and
starting to write code there are many
tasks we should go through beforehand in
order to plan out our code so we ensure
that when the time comes to program it's
a clean and easy process and not riddled
with mistakes and bugs this is where
pseudocode comes into play think of
pseudocode like this if you wanted to
take a family trip to the Grand Canyon
would you simply hop in your car and
drive off and figure out things later no
because I would be ridiculous instead
you would spend some time planning out
the trip what sites or places do you
want to visit
what hotel reservations are you going to
have to make what kinds of things are
you going to do when you get there what
routes or highways are you going to take
and why all of these things must be
determined before you can even think
about hopping in your Ford Explorer so
how does this translate to pseudocode
well think of our family trip to the
Grand Canyon as a program programmers
use pseudocode sudo meaning not real and
code meaning code as a means to plan out
their programs before they write them
just like how we planned out our trip
before going they throw away syntax and
naming conventions for variables and
just focus on what they want the
program to accomplish and how they plan
on doing that pseudocode is very similar
to constructing an outline for a paper
that you're writing you write down the
main topics of the essay and plan out
your major talking points but you don't
worry about the nitty-gritty details of
it all such as word choice grammar
conventions and proper formatting by
doing this we allow ourselves to think
freely and not worry about stressing the
small stuff at least not yet all right
now that we know what pseudocode is
let's talk about how we write pseudocode
you see the best part about pseudocode
is that it can take the form of many
different things for many different
people each computer scientist has their
own methodology for planning out their
code and there are probably hundreds of
different methods of writing pseudocode
that are out there today today however
I'd like to focus on three popular ones
that I think you might find to be
extremely useful the first of these is
known as flowcharts and mainly they can
be used to think through the process of
a particular function a flowchart is
fundamentally a graphical representation
of a function and how it might flow many
programmers do this and lay out the
conditional statements and loops that
they want as different blocks in the
flowchart connected by arrows and
charting out every path of their
function from there it's extremely easy
to create test cases and follow them
through the flow of the function through
the different blocks and arrows for
example we could have a flowchart that
goes something like this a user enters
in a number and if the number is 8 I
want the program to return true however
if the number is not 8 then I wanted to
return false it's a great way to
visualize what the functions overall
purpose is and also look for any errors
that you may have missed when thinking
about the function such as a missing
path it also abstracts the programming
statements up to simple blocks making it
easier to modify or change completely
the best part is that when you have
finished testing cases you can simply
convert the blocks into programming
statements and you have a well-written
function without any debugging another
popular pseudocode technique that is
often used is to simply write out what
you want your code to do chronologically
don't necessarily think about what
programming statements and functions you
want to use just jot down from start to
finish what it is the program you're
writing is going to do step by step
for example let's say you're making an
app that takes in two numbers and
divides them the pseudocode for that
would look a little something like this
first I want to prompt the user to enter
a number and then I want to wait for the
user to enter in that first number after
I get the first number I want to again
prompt the user to input a second number
once they do I complete the operation by
dividing the two numbers entered and
returning the result back to the user
this all seems like it would be common
sense but remember that oftentimes we're
not going to be working with simple
multiplication or division functions we
may be working with full-scale games
algorithms or user interfaces with many
different options this method allows you
the programmer to not get bogged down
with the syntax and conventions that you
have to follow you're simply making a
note of what the program's ultimate goal
should be as if you were explaining it
to a friend of yours this method really
lets you plan out everything that needs
to happen in your program in order for
it to run smoothly it also ensures you
don't forget about a piece of an
algorithm or a certain function that you
need to write in afterwards and the
final pseudocode strategy that I'd like
to talk about to you today is writing
out the main features you want the user
to have when using your program and what
functions or smaller programs you're
going to need to complete these features
let's do another example
say you're making a banking interface
and on startup you want the user to
initially have two options they can set
up a new account or log in to an
existing account from there if they log
into their account then you want them to
have the functionality to withdraw money
deposit money take out a loan or pay
back a loan if they decide to set up a
new account you want them to be able to
create an account store their
information in a database and then
access all of the features that a
returning member would have this may
look very similar to the flow chart
method the only difference being that
this is abstracted one level higher over
an entire program rather than just a
single function if you really wanted to
you could also create a flow chart that
would go through the functionality of
all the four methods described above
setting up a hierarchy like scene on
your screen now makes it easy and clear
to see every function in interface
you're going to have to make this
prevents you from having to try
shoehorn a function or feature into an
already finished program at the last
second which is not a very fun
experience in the slightest so there you
have it three pseudocode strategies you
can use to plan out your code before you
even start writing any the flowchart
method which is good for thinking
through the flow of a certain function
the write up method which is good for
getting the general idea down for a
program or the functionality planning
method good for listing out the
functions of a certain program you can
use all of them none of them a mixture
of them or even disregard these and find
and create your own pseudocode methods
the main goal here is to drastically
minimize the amount of errors that occur
during your program and relieve a lot of
stress on your head the importance of
pseudocode cannot be stressed enough and
if you don't believe me I urge you to
try to complete a large project without
it okay so if you've watched the series
up until this point you've gotten a
pretty good understanding of many
aspects of programming and also how to
plan out your programs now it's time to
go out into the real world and write
some actual code but what kind of
program I can hear you asking me and the
answer is truly whatever you want really
as I'm sure you know by now you can
program just about anything you have on
your mind
anything from simple games to complex
software this video has equipped you
with the basics that are going to need
to be used in pretty much any program
you decide to write but that doesn't
mean that every programming language is
perfect for every application each
language has its own strengths and
weaknesses and choosing the right one is
very important for making it easier and
sometimes just even possible for you to
program what you want so that's what we
are going to be talking about now
choosing the best language for what you
want to accomplish now we talked earlier
about low level versus high level
programming languages in case you forgot
let's do a quick refresher higher level
programming languages have a higher
level of abstraction from machine
language that series of zeros and ones
from way back when while lower level
programming languages have a low level
of abstraction from machine language for
example block programming where you can
drag and drop programming statements
together like 2d Legos would be a high
level language as it does not take a
high level
understanding of the inner workings of a
computer to program it the theoretical
highest level of a programming language
would be if I could just write down what
I wanted the computer to do in simple
English and it would just work but sadly
that doesn't exist yet on the other side
of the spectrum the lowest level
programming language would be just
feeding zeros and ones into the computer
at supersonic speed which would be
almost impossible and extremely absurd
so how do you choose what type of
language is best for your needs well it
depends on what you are trying to do as
sometimes you need very specialized
languages to get done what you want the
world of computer science is vast and
contains many fields so trying to cover
everything in one language would be
impossible this has led to the creation
of hundreds of different programming
languages each designed for a specific
task right now though we'll cover some
of the most popular languages and their
uses now if you are trying to design a
website using HTML and CSS is probably
your best bet HTML is a markup language
that is designed for writing the content
of a web site while CSS is great for
designing the style of the website you
interact with HTML every day and you can
even see it right now if you right click
and hit inspect element this will truly
show you how complex HTML and CSS can be
maybe it would be best for you to use a
scripting language a scripting language
is a language that has many commands for
you to use and that can also be run
without needing to be compiled scripts
can be faster to write in most programs
and tend to be easier to port between
operating systems allowing for
cross-platform support scripts can also
be used with websites oftentimes adding
to the overall user experience of the
site if you want to go into web design
this might also be a path for you to go
down examples of scripting languages are
Perl PHP Ajax and JavaScript for most
programs you could probably use a
general-purpose language general-purpose
languages as they sound have a wide
range of applications usually these
should be your go-to languages examples
of general-purpose languages are Java
C++ and Python
they each have their own different
benefits over one another Java is very
useful for developing games and
interactive web pages Python can act as
a scripting language for web programming
as well as writing applications and data
analysis and C++ tends to be used for
writing applications and system programs
they all have a variety of packages that
you can import and use to achieve the
functionality you need from them while
selecting the right general-purpose
language for your big projects is very
important for most of your programs any
one of them will work it really comes
down to preference get to know each
language and decide which one's syntax
rules you like best and find most
comfortable if you get to know one
general-purpose language really well and
enjoy programming with it you can apply
to just about any of the programs you
plan on writing personally I tend to use
Python for most of my projects this is
mostly not due to any functional
difference between Python and any other
general-purpose language though there
are a few but it is mainly because I
find its syntax rules most convenient
and easiest to write programs with
overall either you can consider the
product you plan on doing and research
and see which language boasts the most
advantages for your purposes or you can
simply become comfortable with a
language and use it from most of the
programs you decide to write
we'll now be looking at our final topic
of this introduction to programming
miniseries you now have the basic
knowledge of programming which will take
you far in any language that you decide
to learn you know some good
pre-programming pseudocode strategies to
help you design your code from the
ground up and you might already have a
good idea as to the type of programming
language you might want to start with so
what's the next step how can I learn
that language and what applications can
it be used for well that's what we're
gonna be covering now so let's just jump
right into it starting with the biggest
question which is what is the next step
well now that you might know which type
of language you might be interested in
research that language and find out
whether or not you truly want to pursue
that programming language most languages
like Python or C++ will have either an
official website where you can read up
on the language or a Wikipedia page
which will provide you with useful
information in deciding whether or not
you want to pursue that path from there
the next step is to actually learn the
language which can be done right here on
YouTube while we have taught you the
basics of any programming language each
specific language is going to expand
upon these concepts and so watching
tutorial videos on a certain language is
going to be very beneficial I would
start with an introduction series like
the one you're currently watching but
for the language you have chosen and
work your way through that series
picking up on the syntax and rules of
that language until you become
comfortable with it once you do that you
come to a crossroads you know how to
program in a certain language but you
may be completely clueless as to what to
make in that language
programmers block can leave you
uninspired and not want to continue
programming so I'd like to give you a
few websites to help out first is coding
bat a completely free website which has
hundreds of coding challenges in both
Java and Python to help you or find your
programming skills and even learn some
new programming shortcuts and tips this
is great if you want to get better at
improving your efficiency and need
something to hone your skills as a
developer
the next is coder bite which offers over
200 plus challenges that you can
complete in over 10 different languages
something that is sure to help you
improve the final website I'd like to
talk about is hacker rank which not only
provides programming challenges to
keep you on your toes but also provide
support for you using your programming
skills to find jobs or internships these
and many more websites exist solely to
keep you interested in code and work on
refining your skills to become better
now if you're a teenager watching this
series in high school I also encourage
you to take programming classes in your
high school AP computer science
principles and AP Computer Science a are
both amazing courses which can help you
greatly in the future and are also
incredibly informative and important to
colleges your school might also offer
other classes in the fields of computer
science including ones on key data
structures game design and data science
any in all classes you can take to help
expand your knowledge of programming and
help you find your niche is going to be
extremely helpful as you can see the
world of code has now been opened up to
you these are just a few examples of
where you can go from here but there are
many more we didn't talk about you could
get into github and start contributing
to projects you could work on your own
projects and collaborate with others the
possibilities are endless the next step
is up to you this concludes our
introduction to programming mini-series
we hope you enjoyed watching it as much
as we enjoyed making it if you enjoyed
the series as a whole
consider subscribing to our channel
mobile pointer exception which will be
linked in the description for more
content like this coming soon thank you
so much for watching